the following audio is from a press
round table for
jean-pierre darden and luke darden the
filmmakers behind
two days one night this audio features a
round table interview with the film's
lead actress
marion cottiard and writer director
brother team jean-pierre darden and luke
darden
two days one night opens in new york
city december 24th
2014 and expands to la and beyond
in january 2015. a written transcript of
this audio can be found
on filmcourage.com
um was it difficult to do the belgian
accent for you
um
yes or no
okay well kind of i was
because i didn't want to i didn't want
to have like a belgium accent i wanted
to
um to have a flavor
and i needed it because my
i mean all the other actors
and especially the the actor who plays
my husband
and and the the two young actors who
plays my kids
they have an accent and i it
is actually the first one of the first
things if not the first thing the darden
brothers
asked me it was to lose my parisian
accent
um when you're asked such a thing
usually i mean james gray wanted me to
have
a polish accent or guillain-cane wanted
me to have an italian accent or
usually i work on oh i had one here
thank you thank you very much um
so you have a dialect coach and you work
for
hours days weeks months when you're
lucky enough to have months
but then here it was losing my french
parisian accent so i thought i need to
replace it by something
uh another accent i mean we all have
accents or we're robots you know
so i thought okay i need to have a
belgium accent
but it is not what they asked me
and they're very precise in their
demands
so i knew they they were not asking me
to have a belgium accent but
and then the month of rehearsal that we
had was very helpful
because i listened to all those people
around me who had a
different kind of belgium accent accents
and um
and not that it yeah i was i was kind of
nervous
that it would be too much or not enough
and because i was working by myself no
dialect coach this time
uh sometimes i got a little nervous
about it
and sometimes they would say oh no no
this is too
too much of a of a leisure accent
and i was very happy about it but then i
knew that i needed to reduce
so it would not be disturbing
because some people in the audience
know my face already which was kind of
new for the darden brothers to work with
a well-known actress and
and i knew that i really needed to fit
in their world
but that the accent shouldn't be
disturbing
for the audience
that was a long
hi answer hi great job thank you i just
wanted to ask you it was interesting
that this movie is kind of like a road
movie
um yeah and it's also a reawakening of a
romance because
in the beginning you know they're not
having sex they've you know they're sort
of estranged and everything and then by
the end of it they've come back together
so for you i mean how did you see this
film when you
first read it when you read the script
what did you think of it how did you
picture it like either genre-wise or
maybe
divide a genre for you what did you
think
um when i first read the script it
resonated with
some deep questions and reflections that
i had a year and a half before
when i read a letter of someone who
had decided to end his life
because he was working in a company
and and at that time a lot of people in
that company
took the same decision as this guy
so it was a big thing in france and one
of them left a letter
explaining that he was
putting an end to his life because he
felt useless
and um
and some other another person had
kids too and i started to
really question
i mean i've always questioned our
society
and the decisions and the how it
functions or how it dysfunctions
but um i was reading at the same time
some
i was reading things about indian tribes
or african tribes
and never i read
somewhere that an
individual in these tribes
questioned uh um
uh his or her places in
in in the society and
um so of course i came to
the conclusion that we our society
the society will live in here created
isolation and this question that is
that should should sound
crazy in a perfect world where
everybody on earth has a place otherwise
this person wouldn't be here if
this person didn't have a place and a
purpose or
you know well and um
and so when i read the script the first
time it really like
brought back all these questions and
reflections that i had and it made
sense for me to experience from the
inside
someone who feels useless
and worthless
a quick question sort of following up on
that your performance is so it's
such a subtle performance it's not showy
and it's filled with a lot of
like raw vulnerability and nuance how
did the rehearsal
process kind of did that help with kind
of nailing the subtle
subtleness of like working class mothers
and stuff
that kind of help the rehearsal the
five-week reversal
well rehearsals uh always help
because you
um i remember when i started being an
actress i read this biography from
romishnider i don't know if you're
familiar with this
genius actress and
at the beginning of her biography she
says
she always worked a lot um
on preparing uh for a role
and she was kind of a model for me she
is
still but and she
says i'm gonna work
on a character and i'm gonna explore
50 ways
most of the time the first way is
the right way but it's enriched
by exploring the 49
other ways and when you have the time to
rehearse you try things
and you can go wrong because you're not
shooting
and then the next day you you're gonna
try something different
and it's gonna be richer because you've
experienced what was
not exactly what you're looking for
but then you experienced it um
and especially when
well i always i always need a
preparation time
because i love it first of all i love
this process
of exploring because when you find
something and
it's like it's like a gold
serter you don't say that a gold i mean
when you search golden you have the gold
you know and then you like suddenly wow
that's it
and you have time to digest
to make it better
and i need that time because i
one of my favorite parts if there is one
because i love the whole process
but it's when you start feeling
the character in your body and
i i cannot
work only on what's in her mind
what's what was her life before which is
something that i love to do but when i
start
feeling that the way i
walk the way i talk the way i breathe
becomes her
and and then i see myself disappearing
and rehearsals is
it was the first time for me i did this
uh
a process of rehearsing with the
directors and we rehearsed
all the scenes on sets
with the actors and even in costumes
it was not this process of rehearsing
was not
focused on acting um
it was finding the dynamic of the camera
because it was all sequence shots
sometimes you have a scene that lasts 10
minutes
and we really had to create the
choreography
and and the darden's cinema is
there's the rhythm is really really
important
in their movies and they're very
demanding
um i mean in terms of
rhythm sometimes i would have the scene
i i get off the bed put my shoes on
and i put the left shoes and when i put
the right shoes
i burst in tears we did it like 80 times
and sometimes it would happen on the
left shoes or when i would put my
foot back on the floor and they would
come and they would say that was great
but if you can really like burst into
exactly when you put your shoes on that
was that
that level of precision um
which i really really loved but um
but then the rehearsal time was really
like focused on finding the dynamic and
of course finding the dynamic
is also about acting because what you
give
gives a rhythm and and then you
and then you try to do a beautiful cake
with all those
elements um but
then when you're on set
it's all about acting they're focused
on acting which is heaven
for an actor um i think did i answer
your question and more than that
correct when you're on set when you're
going from scene to scene
by moment what's the key for you as an
actress to actually stay in the moment
no matter what
filmmaker or or a dp you're working with
or scene partner you're working with is
there a key that you found over the
years
that puts you right there
a good director that's the key
if i if i don't want to give
because i'm not in a trust
i mean i don't trust the director it's
really really hard for me to give
anything and to
to find the authenticity to find
everything i need to
to give everything i have to give to a
scene
so that's the first thing and then
if i feel free
and if i
if there's a strong connection
with the people i work with
i it's not hard for me to just
to stay in the character i mean but
sometimes i mean
sometimes i know that i need a process
um
i need time by myself before the
day when i did lavion rose for example i
always
came an hour before the call
because i needed this hour to do stuff
to get in um
but when i yeah when i feel free and
and trusted and i trust the people i
work with
um it's simpler
you've said that um you go so deep into
a role sometimes that it's almost well i
tried to
to come out yeah that how was that for
sandra how did you go into her and then
how did you come out of sandra's whole
psyche of the
being nervous the depression did you
find yourself
struggling to understand thing is
as i find the process of getting in very
interesting
i find the process of getting out
very interesting too um
i didn't know before
lavion rose that i would have to find a
way out
i thought it was a job and that after
the last cut i would go back to my life
and go back to
normal i would i was about to say well
it might be
that normal what is normal anyway
but that was a very very interesting
process
that took me a long time
and then i realized that i needed
to do it for almost all the
movies and i never know how it's gonna
happen so
i'm always looking for this uh
experience um
it can take the form of
someone who will tell me something and
we're
going to enter a discussion and then
suddenly i will feel that it's going
away it's it's really hard to explain
and
but i learn a lot out of it
it's kind of hard to explain and i never
know how it's going to happen
jamie hi hi um i wanted to follow up on
a few things you were talking
about before about directors because you
work with so many great directors
and different types of directors from
woody allen chris for nola and
tim burton goes on and on working with
the dodens and their
different style and approach to making
films what was that experience like for
you and what are you
looking for from a director when you're
working on
um
i i need to work with
directors who
need more than anything to tell a story
i worked with directors and i found out
working with them
then that
if they were there or in
anywhere else it would make no
difference
and it was painful because
i needed to be almost a matter of life
or death
you know because first of all when you
when you do a movie it involves
a lot of people who trust you
and it's and you will ask
people to come to see what you want to
say
and if it's not something that you
really need to say i'm not interested
um because it's too painful for me
and it happened and and it was i was
totally lost
because i was with someone who who would
who was not in the deep
need to tell a story so that's
one thing um
the darden brothers
something that i loved about i loved
everything this is
one of the greatest experiences if not
the greatest experience that i had
on set with directors and the
relationship that i had with them was
total osmosis osmosis
um
they always talk about the audience
when sometimes onset audience is like
a bad word they
always talk about the audience and
that's what i love about their movies
because they take you somewhere and
they're gonna surprise you
and they're gonna move you they're gonna
i mean i've seen all their movies i love
them all
for me the sun is a masterpiece i don't
know if you've seen this movie but
this is
i mean for an audience taking a road and
then suddenly
someone is going like and then you turn
and
the story is totally different from what
you
thought entering the theater and for 30
minutes
you think that i mean i won't ruin
anything if if some people haven't seen
this movie but
obviously you think something you think
that this guy is
this kind of person and then suddenly
it's totally it
it unravels
something totally different i mean as
part of an audience
for me it's like
it's what cinema is for you know
and um on the second day of rehearsals
they were talking about the audience and
that was funny because it was really new
for me and it was
really like
a little more freedom they had already
given me
a freedom that was beyond freedom but
this was
i loved it so much and they turned to me
and they said oh you know
we talk about the audience all the time
and the first scene is no we don't want
the audience to see your face
as in almost all their movies
and and then
and then they're gonna do this and the
audience will think this and then
they will be surprised by this
information well it's
i found it relieving
um i don't know if i answered all your
questions
do you have time for one more question
the classic ending question can i ask
what you're uh
up to right now what do you have lined
up project project-wise
i am i did a movie
at the beginning of the year uh a
british movie based on macbeth
um so i think that's going to be
released next year
you're lady at the bat i am
i hope but is it traditional
super traditional and we went to the
purest shakespeare
you could find because sometimes they
kind of adapt a little bit for people to
understand
if you don't it's normal now
uh well it took me a long time to
understand everything
but i'm french
um is that with mac michael fassbender
yeah
yeah and this director it's his second
movie but this guy is gonna
is gonna count um who's the character
justin kurtzel he's an australian
director and it's
his second movie and um so you're going
to follow up this movie with a comedic
movie obviously
i'm not talking to you anymore
i would love to i'm asleep
when i accepted my next movie
first of all my boyfriend was like oh
it's going to be a fun year
and then well already when because i was
not supposed to
to do a movie after the darden brothers
movie because i was kind of
um exhausted and then justin came
with this offer and i always knew i
would play macbeth but i thought it
would be on stage and in french and i
thought well this is an opportunity that
that i cannot you know miss
and same boyfriend said are you
kidding me because he knows i want to do
comedies
he's like are you kidding me lady
macbeth
i mean this must be a joke
and my next movie is not funny
drama um drama it's um
um a french movie from uh
a french director actor she's an actress
and a director
she's called nicole garcia and no it's
not going to be a fun movie but
i mean i'm i'm looking forward to did
you have fun doing the bit in anchorman
i was so stressed out because i'm not
used to do comedies and
when you're not used to do that you
never
know if the level of what you do is too
high or too low
and plus you're on screen with genius
jim carrey
and all those people who are just my
heroes
and i was um yeah i felt
i i had fun and at the same time i was
so stressed
out that it it kind of ruined a little
bit of the fun
especially that i can i say that
i was supposed to shoot the next day and
they pushed the day before and i was
totally hangover
because the med ball was the night
before
but no i mean i had so much fun and i'm
i really wanted to come
a comedy i don't know if i would
i mean i would have a lot of work maybe
maybe more work than
for a drama because i'm familiar with
drama now um
but that would be yeah that would be a
risk that i would love to take
thank you so much thank you thank you
thank you
thank you very much hello bonjour
um i love the movie so wonderful
and it fits in line with a lot of your
other similarly themed
films and i'm wondering what about her
story
was it that you wanted to tell because
there's similar things to
working class into family and value
the value of money so i'm wondering what
about her story
was it the question is
um
at the start we wanted to tell a story
about a woman who has no confidence who
lacks
confidence first of all in herself and
secondly
in others and because after all all
these
other employees voted against her hello
so we wanted to uh talk about
her journey and a journey where
she gains confidence through solidarity
first of all
with her husband secondly with her
co-workers who are
in solidarity with her at the onset
juliet and robert
and then further along with the
solidarity
of the other workers that turn around
and decide to work for her and we wanted
to tell that journey about her
overcoming
this lack of confidence and this fear
that she had
through this process beautiful thank you
and auntie um i i was
very curious about the the challenges um
number one
i saw that you shot in chronological
order and i'm wondering if you can tell
us about the challenges of that
as well as do you always have that many
rehearsals
before actual shooting
for five weeks we always rehearse for a
lengthy period of time
and in this case we had a lot of actors
so
we always do the rehearsals on the
locations
where we're going to shoot so all the
blocking's done at the same time
i'm going to continue to answer in terms
of the long takes
each sequence a sequential shot
is one encounter that sandra has
with other people another individual
and we felt that it was important to
have these long takes and these
uh encounters because that way
the audience member can go through what
sandra is going through
in the encounter simultaneously
we feel that these sequential takes
allow the film to breathe that they
allow it to really live
that there's that you have a feeling of
real life happening in front of you
i was going to ask the gentleman this is
a very universal
film especially in the past couple years
there's been
a recession in europe united states
other places
i'm just curious where you've shown this
elsewhere have you also
had people come up to you talk to you
about their own experiences in terms of
dealing
with the situation of people having to
fight for their jobs
universe
well of course i mean in a lot of places
we we meet people that you know have
lost their jobs and that are struggling
with employment
and to come back to what we were saying
before
is in the film we
part of what we're trying to do and what
we're trying to say it's it's a response
to the economic crisis
situations
well and it's true that in our region in
the locality of where we shoot i mean
it's a very omnipresent
uh problem i mean it's it's it's
very present and yesterday in brussels
there in fact there was um a
march a manifestation with a hundred and
twenty thousand people
that were crying out against the
lowering of salaries
okay thank you jamie
uh i wanted to ask about casting
marianne and with an actress of her
caliber
is there much direction that she needs
much adjustment
or does she basically direct herself
second marion is
foreign
well i think that in the rehearsal
process i mean the way we work with
mahila we we work the same with her as
we work with all of the other actors
for example during those five weeks of
rehearsal we try to find what's going to
be the form
the structure of the film for instance
the sequential
shots
okay comedy
and what happens with the actors during
these five weeks
is that we try to strip away their
defenses as much as possible or totally
and us too we will also want to be naked
vis-a-vis the actors
so that the characters can can can be
born that they can start to emerge
and exist
quite so we want to
strip the actors of any kind of
mannerisms
ticks or stereotypical sort of character
responses
etcetera etcetera comedians
and the most important thing for us is
to find that the actors
really start to exist within the
characters and that there
are not in a performance mode
so it's a work process in which we
are involved in and the actors are
involved in so it's a total mix
now we do say you know we do say like
we'd like the scene to start here we'd
like to end it here
there is that that's not a job
and you do it well bonjour
uh for the brothers sandra's journey to
approach all of her coworkers to keep
the job
how does that mimic your own journey to
find financiers
for your projects
very finely put
i'm wondering first of all thank you i
love your film very powerful and
meaningful
i'm wondering if you could speak a
little bit more about the support of
manu
for sandra it's very different from some
of your earlier films where
the main character has been sort of an
outsider
who doesn't have support
yeah it's true in this in this film
there is a family in family
a functional family i mean a family that
is really
unified in our other films it's true
that the the characters are often much
more alone
helped us enormously in terms of this
film because he allowed us to
be inside and outside but always having
the connection
hello
foreign
allowed several things first of all you
know he was that first element
of solidarity and he allowed us to tell
things about the movie that preceded the
movie
in a way um it allowed us you know to
link him with the depression
you know there was that aspect and then
his he was really the first
uh anchor of solidarity before the other
workers so it allowed us to go inside
and outside and to keep that connection
going
and also it's that manu i mean it's not
enough it's no longer enough today
for the woman to have the love of her
husband and her children and to have
their approbation within the household
she also needs
to to be affirmed in the outside world
and manu is very aware of that and so he
supports that
in her journey to be recognized she
needs to be recognized by her co-workers
by society
outside not just inside the house and he
aids in that process
exactly it's going to ask you um
as she goes around making her case to
her co-workers to reconsider and
vote again in her behalf
she never mentions to any of them i
don't think
that she i have children you know i need
the money because i have children
she doesn't go down that that road she
she makes her case for everything else
except for that and i was just wondering
why was that
well because uh you know at one point
when manu
says to her you have to go out and see
them one by one to try to get them to
change your mind
and she says well no i can't do that
that's like being a beggar that's like
begging
be
and we felt as filmmakers you know given
that that was in her character that if
she went
and then she started to talk about her
children
that it was not no longer she was no
longer asking for solidarity she was
asking for pity in charity
and
and we didn't want that as filmmakers we
didn't want that for the film because
the subtext the undercurrent is that
when she goes and sees these people even
the people that did not agree with her
that voted against her
she's saying she's saying to them put
yourself in my shoes put yourself in my
place but at the same time
she kind of understands their place i
mean and that creates
the undercurrent of a constant of
solidarity that is throughout
that theme throughout the film
yeah the film is not it's not a trial i
mean she's not going
to see people and saying okay this is a
good guy this is a bad guy and she
goes there totally unjudgemental
unjudgementally and there's no room
in that characterization for pity
that's not what she's looking for
um as as as brothers you've been
directing films your entire life
i'm wondering if you could talk about
the other's style
and strengths that the audience might
not know
or that you both find in each other
when we start writing but after that
no i know
can i follow up on that question your
second nature
of what you're explaining sort of
knowing how each other
works do you feel that that comes from
working with each other for so long or
because of your as prisoners
i don't know
i don't know but i i don't think you can
do what we're doing
if you're not brothers
yeah i don't think you know neither of
us are trying to be the one it's not a
contest about which one is right
uh but i think that there has to be
i'm not saying we necessarily have to
have the same mother
but that there has to be there
but there needs to be i believe a
profound link that goes back to
childhood
in order to work the way we work
together
and we have time for one more question i
don't think kate didn't have a chance
go ahead thank you bonjour um at the end
of the film
ultimately the decision about
whether sandra keeps her job rests with
her how did you arrive at that
conclusion
almost
shoes hello it took a while for us to
come up
with that ending but in order for it to
come full circle
we needed sandra to get to the point
where
she was put in the position that the
others were put in where she kept saying
put yourself in my shoes and then she
was in a position where she had to put
herself in somebody else's shoes at the
end
he passed tomorrow and put herself
in their shoes
and that's why because she is has come
to the point where she was able to put
herself
in somebody's shoes and make the
decision that she made at the end of the
film
that allows her to come out of it saying
i'm happy and we really put up a good
fight
and she speaks to her husband and we
was that something that was attached to
you or was that because it was a cheaper
well we chose um first of all we you
know we like
van morrison and he was very very nice
with us
um but we chose that song because it
allowed
in the car it allowed there was a
refrain
and for the three to then have that
moment of solidarity where they sing
together uh really kind